thank you
all right so living with meat Aquarius
um this is more about how VIP has first
of all I'm Alex Lee I work at behance
now part of adobe
um yeah don't be family
um but we build
so we build behance.net uh it's a site
with a lot of creative portfolios
and we're essentially there to Showcase
their portfolios but we run into the
problem of needing or wanting to
Showcase it in as two as wide audience
as possible which means reaching out to
all sorts of devices all sorts of
platforms uh so we can't just have
mobile apps which we do have we also
need the site to be responsive
um and this we determined early on the
best way to do this is not to have
separate versions of the site for uh
every single device is coming out there
with way different
um
sizes and formats and all kinds of
things the best way to do this is just
to have one site that is going to
respond
um and so we ran into some challenges
trying to trying to get this to happen
and here's the the problems that we we
came up with
first thing you realize when you try to
build a responsive site is that if you
have lots of UI that users users are
interacting with but in order to
maintain the UI and have the UI display
when they should hide when they
shouldn't you have to have all these Dom
nodes on the page and then you're using
CSS media uh yeah media queries in order
to hide and show these things as soon as
you have I don't know something like 50
different dialogues on the page every
there's you just get rampant with these
style sheets and they just get out of
hand there's no way to fix that there's
also the problem of Behavioral
Divergence because we are a design
driven company as our founder would say
um and what that really means is that
the design team designs some pretty
outlandish behaviors for when certain
things start to behave drastically
differently so when you're on the
desktop everybody understands how you
use the website on the computer but once
you start shrinking down the the form
factor you start shrinking down the
screen the website starts becoming very
different it has to behave differently
and uh I'll show you that uh some some
of that in a bit and then lastly the API
Dom's API is um
difficult
it's not the prettiest thing in the
world
so we also wanted something to hide
developers it would hide the Dom API
from the Developers
so here's an example
um that's an awful resolution
what you see here is essentially the
design for uh our inbox
um
this is a classic list of um lists of
messages and a detail on the other side
so you have a master detail view
um pretty understandable to everybody
using a desktop well yeah
but then you get to the mobile ah Jesus
there we go
so you get to the bubble View and it
becomes drastically different because
you start out on the left side this is
your landing page uh you land here and
then you have a list of things you have
to click on it to open it up you're able
to scroll through them but you have to
click on it open it up when you click on
it open it up it opens it up into this
view that takes over the entire screen
you have your UI completely replaced
with an X and then when you get out of
that list view you have to go back to
the same scroll position as you were
before
and if you're trying to do this with CSS
only you're gonna have a bad time
uh let's see where's my mouth
so this is where we started coming up
with uh different solutions for doing
this the best thing we have is an
interaction breakpoint all the
interaction breakpoint is we are
separating logically what CSS sees as
breakpoints from what JavaScript sees as
breakpoints and the CSS world is way
more concerned about display on the
JavaScript World we're less concerned
about display and more concerned about
at what points in the page do I need to
start behaving differently so that the
user's interactions are
consistent with what their expectation
is so when they see something different
they want to they want to interact with
it in a different way as well
so I'm gonna need a couple things for
this uh you're gonna need to know which
media query you're currently looking at
you're going to need to know when you
have entered and exit different media
queries and also you need to be respond
to all that and then change the view
accordingly
and you want to do that last bit the
least do not Dom as much as possible
so
that's okay
so that's how you would do it with a raw
Dom API with match media match media
returns you an object which has matches
it's a Boolean about whether or not your
current
media is matching that media query is
matching and it also has this nice thing
called add listener no no that's ad
listener not ad event listener
way to go down
um
so that's something that we have but
that's kind of tedious I don't want to
have that all over my code I don't want
to have media query stated all over my
code I don't want to copy that string
everywhere
so what we did is we put it in our
essentially utility Library layer
um mbdjs is something that we have it
provides an MVC layer utilities tools of
great things for us so what we have is a
a media module and in the media module
you're studying as an object a
breakpoint name that matches onto a
media query so that when you're going
through this
all that the rest of your code deals
with is the breakpoint name so for this
we have to find phone tablet and desktop
and that is all that we want to deal
with and that helps you just cut off
everything else and think about only
things as being on the phone or desktop
or tablet
and what that also allows us to do is to
provide a much better interface for the
events
um it will when you cross boundaries of
a media query it will fire the enter or
exit events
so that's what we did oh also as a note
this is all es6 now it's not follow it
get used to it
um on the other side of it so we have
hat we have half the battle one which is
how to manage all the things that are
changing
on the other side we have to listen to
what has changed and you know provide
the correct view for the user so
responsive entities is what we what we
came up with and responsive entities
they need to be sensitive to Media
queries
but we should not the consumer of those
entities should not know about them at
all to the consumer of the entity they
are just dealing with any regular thing
that they want rendered
so here's what we would like
we would like
just like that when you saw the message
from Eric I said your work is tolerable
one of my favorite messages
um you construct a message and you
render that message that's all you want
to do that's all you ever want to really
deal with
and you'll note that there's nothing in
here about what breakpoint you're at
what media queries you're dealing with
all of that is hitting Away by the
responsive entity
so this gives us a consistent interface
for how to deal with things
um then we have to set up the
breakpoints we're saying okay you can
use any arbitrary uh media querying here
so you can do orientation changes
um
then you get to the views
so the views are essentially
encapsulations of the view right the the
encapsulation of all the behavior that
goes along with an entity
that means you can have completely
Divergent markup completely Divergent
behavior and you can bind them all
together in one single uh one single
entity one single class that you object
that you throw around so
you can have uh this is uh template
strings you can have template strings
template out things for you and I didn't
put it in here because it was
Troublesome you can just bind whatever
Behavior you you want in this
um
we have our own views but you can use
backbone views if you will if you have
them
so the point at which it all comes back
together is the controller so in MVD we
have a responsive controller that all it
does is listen on to the media module
that I showed earlier and
uh
if buying onto the media module and then
listens for changes as
as those changes come along but what you
have is a nice statement down here of
what maps to what so in the previous one
we have short and long as different
classes of fuse here we're saying short
and long match to certain breakpoints so
in the case where you are at a vertical
breakpoint you use the short
view when you're in a horizontal
breakpoint use a Long View so that frees
us and that
really cuts down at the amount of uh
different concerns at every different
level so that we have really thin
controllers mostly thin views because
man they want a lot of interactions in
those views
and a really thin model so we like to
keep everything thin we don't mind
having more of everything just having
thin things also allows for better
reusability
so here's the point where I demo this
and
see if I can see this you can also go to
this on your phone to to look at it
so
is this going to let me click
I don't know if anybody's using their
phones to look at this so I don't want
to
away from this
so here is
there we go
so this
this page is the same code that I've had
before
um let me see if I can show you
what the code behind it is like
ah damn it not gonna show me that
I'm gonna show me the right thing
um but
ah where's my mouse there it is uh the
the thing about this is I can rotate
this to simulate a orientation change
and as soon as I simulate the
orientation it should change it changes
the view and the code that actually runs
all of that is if I can find it
right here
sorry I'm sorry I didn't think that
people would want in want to zoom into
hello world
so
um this is transpiled so it's a little
bit
um
different but essentially this is the
same code that you saw before you have a
media declaration you have the two
different views then you have a
controller at the bottom that binds them
all together
um finally at the bottom I don't know if
you can actually see that at the bottom
is where it renders the thing where you
just create a message with the body
world and then it just renders it so
nice clean API for your responsive
JavaScript thing
yeah and I should probably get out of
the mobile view there we go
and that's it that's it for me
so questions
yes
yes match media is the key that provides
all the functionality yet we wouldn't
want but it's part of the Dom API and
it's
difficult to manage right
supporters available
it is supported on okay so the match
media API for JS supported on IE 10 and
above
on ie9 you're able to get media queries
but the match media API is either
missing or wonky really strange
yeah
there are polyfills
um the lucky thing for us is that we
have a great deal of influence well
because our audience is wholly different
our audience is very much uh Safari
Chrome Firefox at the bottom
um so we can say that for IE the the
section of IE that is below nine we're
going to either partially support or not
really
yes
is that
Source yes mbd.js is open sourced
at uh let's see
that's there we go
wow it's huge there you go oh by the way
it stands for no big deal just saying
even the JS party is an acronym we don't
take our acronyms lightly at the hands
all right
um this is open source uh you can find
it at that URL or you know just search
for behance it's whatever open source
things
no it does not
because es6
the ESX transpiler that uh the one I was
using is from Square uh and the
transpiler I only heard about it way
after mbdjsk now
but I would like to write a version for
es6 except by the time that happens I
will need less than 50 of this Library
because this provides promises
Dominic
but promises now Firefox has native
promises so it's like uh why do I even
need my own code I don't really want it
yeah
any other questions
oh that's it